British politics are in chaos this
morning after a stunning setback for
Prime Minister Boris Johnson our
position lawmakers are trying to pass a
law to stop Johnson from taking Britain
out of the EU without a divorce
agreement so-called No Deal brexit could
send shockwaves through the world
economies including the US Marshall
ipsus outside parliament in London mark
what does this mean for the Prime
Minister
well good morning well when Boris
Johnson came into office he said he had
a plan for getting Britain out of the
European Union talk tough and if he
didn't get a deal walk away no matter
what the consequences well it turns out
the consequences for him and for the
country are not great the eyes to the
right
328 the nose to the left 301 not a good
start at all for Boris Johnson the man
President Trump said would do a great
job as prime minister in his first test
since taking office he lost so the eyes
have it the vote means Johnson's one
negotiating car his threat to walk away
from the European Union at the end of
next month with or without a new trade
deal is now effectively off the table
Johnson's response to threaten to call
an election B's vote tomorrow to stop
negotiations and that would be the only
way to resolve this the opposition's
response bring it on
but only after a No Deal brexit is no
longer an option
he wants the table of motion for a
general election fine
gets the bill through
Boris Johnson no longer has a majority
in parliament the MPs at his own party
but voted against him last night have
been kicked out including by the way the
grandson of Winston Churchill an
election now seems the likeliest outcome
and as for brexit it seems it's ready
for another delay Anthony Mark Phillips
with the commotion in London thanks mark